c'est l'histoire d'un peu de chance et
de hasard des rencontres improbables
entre téhéran et montréal en passant par
broadway
cette histoire c'est celle d'un garçon
qui cherchait un piano ranking chine qui
a nos juniors 16 ans et demi qui veut
devenir compositeur
la musique a toujours été un membre à
part entière de cette famille j'avais
tellement hâte d'aller la garderie juste
pour les chansons dans la voiture nous
sommes dans le téhéran des années 90
vers l'âge de 10 ans ou qui en s'assoit
derrière le piano familial à livry j'ai
très vite compris qu'il ne voulait pas
suivre les partitions vigiles ils
voulaient que ça vienne de lui au nhs
mais elle faisait
[Musique]
comme quand il regarde ce film
d'animation quelques notes d'un air
d'accordéon très parisien donneront
naissance à l'une de ses compositions
favori
[Musique]
qui en suivra seulement trois mois de
formation ses meilleurs moments de
musiciens
[Musique]
so la rupture sera à brut
la famille décide de venir à montréal
pour donner une chance à sa carrière
il ne laisse pas seulement ses amis en
iran il laisse aussi son piano le
deuxième ingrédient pour concocter le
concours de circonstances c'est madhi
samada elle travaille à new york en
architecture et en design urbain
elle était en visite à montréal au
printemps c'était la fin de journée elle
n'avait plus de batterie et le hasard
lannan au palais des congrès j'ai
cherché un point de connexion pour
échanger mon ordinateur
[Musique]
elle trouve une source d'énergie et
tombe sur une source d'inspiration
j'avais le dos tourné donc je n'ai pas
bien qui c'était au début
après deux mois sans pouvoir jouer dans
sa nouvelle ville qui anne a pris
d'assaut ce piano public
imaginez ma surprise quand j'ai vu que
ceux qui réservent les garçons 11 et 12
ordres
et elle n'est pas la seule à tomber sous
le charme extraordinaire
je m'engagerai moutier
chasse près qu'à val-d'or trouve à la
place des arbres
mady le film pendant des dizaines de
minutes
elle lui fait raconter son parcours
j'étais ému ou d'apprendre qu'il est
cherché un piano en hiver ou à jouer et
décide de publier son histoire sur
facebook
j'espérais surtout que ça t'aide et mes
amis musiciens et surtout mes amis de
montréal
lire et son histoire et dans l'airé des
recommandations des bons professeurs de
piano à des prix abordables
et dans les réactions en chaîne il y à
celle ci je pense que je peux leur
trouver un piano signé d'un compositeur
de broadway
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jason nolan qui a eu un grammy en 2015
pour cette comédie musicale toujours
très populaire dans le quartier des
spectacles new york et je ne sais même
pas pourquoi j'étais sur facebook
l'histoire de ce garçon qui cherchait
désespérément à jouer m'a touché
j'imaginais ce que j'aurai ressenti si
je ne vais pas eu accès à un piano quand
j'étais et quelques jours plus tard le
père de qui anne reçoit cette
confirmation de commande un clavier tout
neuf et des écouteurs livré à montréal
des cerises hockey qui en n'y croyais
pas et puis il revient de l'école alors
sous le regard entre autres de chopin je
dédie cette composition à madi samada
âgées sont rasés
[Musique]
le hasard a permis le geste que généreux
d'un étranger
il permet aussi de provoquer le destin
dans un studio de radio canada charles
richard-hamelin l'un des plus grands
interprètes de chopin au québec
[Musique]
ils ne montrent rien mais cette
rencontre donne le tournis à quillane
depuis trois jours quelques clichés pour
immortaliser cet autre geste généreux
donner du temps des conseils et une
oreille il est question de l'admiration
envers ceux qui composent et qui
improvise quillane ajustements écrit une
variation sur chauffant
ce admirable qui a fait tout ce bouche
mais le traitement seul
mais quelque chose dans sa musique qui
fait que ça connaître la crise ont donc
faut pas qu'ils perdent soit il faut
qu'il trouve quelqu'un qui peut juste
d'alimenter c'est un beau message qui
envoie aussi pour sa génération et lui
il y en a plein de jeunes qui ont
souvent un piano à la maison qui n'ont
jamais touché ça c'est juste un beau
meuble induit un navet pop il avait
besoin de trouver un pur pour face à mu
est une histoire où la chance se
conjugue au talent pour forcer un peu le
destin
[Musique]